ومن جهته قال المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي جوناثان كون كريكو ان حادثه
مقتل المختطفين الاسرائيليين في غزه هزت
جميع اركان الجيش برمته واضاف كون كريكس
في مقابله مع السي ان ان ان الجنود الذين
اطلقوا النار على المختطفين في غزه تصرفوا
بشكل مخالف لقواعد الاشتباك على حد
[موسيقى]
قوله انها حادثه تهز قلوب وعقول الجيش
الاسرائيلي من كل الرتب العسكريه وقد اصدر
رئيس الاركان بيانا واضحا للغايه اعلن فيه
تحمل الجيش المسؤوليه الكامله ونعرب
بالطبع عن خالص تعازينا للعائلات المكلومه
انه حادث مساوي تماما والجنود الذين قاموا
باطلاق النار تصرفوا بشكل مخالف لقواعد
الاشتباك ولم يكن يتعين عليهم اطلاق النار
عندما شاهدوا اقتراب الرهائن